l'homme le plus rapide de l'histoire
entre saint-malo et pointe-à-pitre est
donc un suisse laurent bourgnon il a
passé la ligne d'arrivée de la route du
rhum il ya une demi-heure à peine
quatorze jours de mer et une image
maryse burgot un grand homme sur un
grand bateau c'est laurent bourgnon et
son primagaz il est 14h30 en guadeloupe
19h30
en france la voile dressé bien haute
vers pointe à pitre nous renions franchi
dans un calme olympien la ligne
d'arrivée de la route du rhum et déjà on
se précipite pour féliciter le vainqueur
tout ce qu'il ya de fous le détend du
mourion escorté comme il se doit par une
myriade de bateaux dourgne qui vient
d'avaler 7000 km en 14 jours 6h30
bourgnon qui vient donc de battre le
record détenu jusqu'à présent par
florence arthaud